distance makes the heart grow fonder
it's been
months since courtney cox has seen her
boyfriend johnny mcdade
okay no need to panic deep breaths
everyone
the actress revealed that it's been get
this 133 days since we were last
together
talk about commitment the two are
currently quarantined in different
countries
and the couple celebrated johnny's 44th
birthday over video chat
courtney posted this pic on instagram
writing
covit sucks happy birthday jay i love
our lunch
slash dinner la slash london time zoom
date today
i miss you madly hashtag my one
we gotta say this couple has been
thriving during quarantine
now johnny's not quarantining with you
right in may the former friends star was
on the ellen degeneres show and shared
why she and the musician were
quarantining apart
he was supposed to go to switzerland to
write and instead he had to go to
england first
and then all of a sudden that it
happened and they called uh
you know quarantined so i have not seen
him
in so long and i you don't realize we
spend a lot of time on facetime but
now it's like oh my god i just miss you
know
his physical touch just all of it it's
really it's been hard this is the
longest time
in the meantime courtney has been
spending lots of time with her daughter
coco
the 15 year old gave her mom a
quarantine makeover
okay not quite the glam we were
expecting
she's an incredible artist so talented
but hey courtney still looks good while
rocking a smiley face
and a teardrop really does put me in a
better mood
she's also been hanging out with her
former friend's co-star jennifer aniston
and just last month courtney celebrated
her 56th birthday
yep that's the birthday girl killing it
in a teeny tiny black bikini
gracefully diving into her special day
you